- Good afternoon, everyone.
I am Priya Natarajan.
I'm a faculty member in the
Departments of Astronomy
and Physics at Yale,
and also the current director
of the Frankie program
in science and the humanities.
As you all know,
we have been running
this wonderful inference
project series.
And today we have convened
for the postdoc discussion
and conversation led by
professor Zenna Tavares
and he will be engaging with of course,
telling us a lot about his
own work and his perspective
and engaging with the most
recent that we had last week,
given by Kyle Cranmer and
Kyle's talk was titled causality
at the intersection of
simulation, inference,
science and learning.
Before I dive into telling
you a little bit more
about Zenna,
I would like to start out by recognizing
Mr and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke
for their generosity and their
support of this program,
and many other interdisciplinary
activities at Yale.
And just wanted to remind
all of you in the room
that we are recording this event,
and therefore all participants
will have the videos muted
for the duration of the talk.
And as per usual,
questions may be submitted at any time
in the Q and A feature and
that we will get to them.
So as you all saw last Wednesday,
Kyle gave us a sort of a
wonderful overview of the role
of inference in sort of model
building, be it simulations,
dealing with data, large amounts
of data from, for example,
the large Hadron Collider.
And he showed us how
we actually do science
and how we actually learn
by making causal inferences
from events that are
detected for example.
And so today we are going
to hear a fresh perspective
from a slightly different
disciplinary vantage point,
which has been our goal with these talks
and the discussion series.
So for, for, for those of you
who may not yet have seen,
Kyle's talk, the recording
will be available shortly.
And let me just to inform
where Kyle was coming from.
Let me give you his brief biography.
So he's currently a professor
of physics and data science
at New York university
and visiting scientist at,
at Meta AI
in July, he will be become the director
for the American family
insurance data science
Institute at the university
of Wisconsin Madison.
And so his work is really
about frameworks that he's
developed for collaborative
statistical modeling and was
extensively used in the discovery
of the Hicks boon in 2012
with the two separate experiments
that independently made
this discovery.
And he,
his current interests are
sort of at the intersection
of physics, statistics
and machine learning.
Okay.
And for our speaker today,
professor Zenna Tavares,
Zenna Tavares is an
associate research scientist
in both the data science Institute
and the Zuckerman mind
brain behavior Institute.
He's the first joint hire
between two university level
institutes at Columbia at Columbia.
In addition to his Columbia affiliation,
he's also the co-founder of basis,
a new applied AI research
nonprofit organization that aims
to develop universal reasoning
systems and apply them
to help solve hard scientific
and societal problems.
So it shows you the bent that Zenna has
in terms of application
and domains of application
that do step out into societal problems.
And so his research aims to
understand how humans reason
that is how they come to
derive knowledge from observing
and interacting with the world.
He also constructs computational
and statistical tools
to help advance his work
on causal reasoning,
probabilistic programming,
and other related areas.
Prior to joining Columbia,
he was at MIT where he received
a PhD in cognitive science
and statistics,
and was a postdoctoral researcher
in the computer science
artificial intelligence lab
sale Zenna's work has received
enormous recognition,
including an international,
full bright science and
technology award, and you know,
many other accolades
for his papers and work.
I'm not gonna hold take hog more time.
And I would like to invite
Zenna to please take the floor
and just want to say a
thank you to both of you
for speaking to us today.
We are absolutely delighted.
- Thank awesome.
Thank you.
So, yeah, so thanks for the introduction.
Yeah.
And I'm pretty excited to be
here and I'm looking forward
to the discussion.
So let me just try to share my screen.
Great.
So, so the title of my talk
is universal reasoning systems
beyond the frontier of
simulation based inference.
And so this is a kind of
a riff of Kyle's paper,
fantastic paper,
which is the frontiers of
simulation based inference.
And so the general theme of
my talk is gonna be thinking
about what is the current status of kind
of simulation based inference.
And what do I think is a
few steps into the future
and how can we get that?
But this will be in the spirit
of Kyle talk very high level
and hopefully pretty short.
So we can spend most of
the time in the discussion.
So as Priya said, you know,
Kyle does hard and
difficult science, you know,
investigating the nature of the universe,
but my goals are in comparison
a little bit more pedestrian,
a little bit more grounded on, on earth.
And so I'm interested, interested in like,
how can we build machines
that can reason a little bit
better than the current
machines and in particular,
how can we build machines that
are somewhat more humanlike
in their ability to learn
and reason about the world?
And so here are just some kind
of common sense questions,
which a human might be able to answer.
So looking at this picture,
you might say, well, you know,
the driver's drunkenness
likely 'cause this crash,
or if you had a weatherman
give you some rep port,
you might say, well, you
know, that's implausible.
Or if you're an epi epidemiologist,
you might be investigating
some mutation and say,
well, you know,
this is really gonna lead to
some large scale societal,
you know, shutdowns or implications.
And so how can we build machines
that can do this kind
of reasoning right now?
I believe there's no machines
that can really do this,
this degree of, you know,
this degree of general and
flexible info for instance.
So that's kind of my high high level goal.
So the basic foundation upon which
I work is the idea that humans
and presumably many other animals too,
have mental models about
how the world works.
And so her in this
illustration, the idea is that
I, as a human has to model about
the outside physical world.
And so I can, you know,
predict what's gonna happen.
And this is a really powerful
thing to be able to do,
because it means that I can
imagine how the world is gonna
unfold without the
world actually unfolding
that in that particular way.
And that's a very kind of life
preserving faculty to have.
It doesn't necessarily need
to be about physical things
in the world.
I can also reason about
other agents, you know,
think about what you are thinking
thinking about what I'm thinking,
recur up to some depth.
And so there's a variety
of different kinds
of phenomenon in the world.
And the basic premise of
this approach is humans.
They have mental models
and they use these models
to imagine how the world would unfold
in various different ways.
And so my goal is to build
universal reasoning systems
and we can get in the discussion if
that's a meaningful concept, but I,
there are basically
three fundamental pillars
that we need to think about.
At least three.
One is the notion of
knowledge representations.
And again, building enough,
Carl's talk some of the
most exciting workers,
simulation based models as, as
representation of knowledge.
The second bit of it is like
different kinds of modes,
of reasoning,
different kinds of questions
that we might be able to ask.
And the third is different
rhythms for inference,
and this is more the
computational perspective.
And so what I wanna do in this,
in this brief talk is to look
at these different aspects
and in each kind think about, you know,
one aspect of where we are right now.
And another aspect of like where we might
be in the future.
Okay.
So thinking about modes of reasoning.
And so this is a slide from,
from Carl talk and he points
to kind of base BA inference
as this principle foundation.
And so what is the premise
behind BA inference?
Well, the basic idea is
that you have some data,
you have some theory or
some model and given some,
and given these two pieces of information,
I can update using base the, to derive,
what should I believe now,
conditional on the
evidence more generally,
I think of Beijing inference
as a paradigm for logical inference.
And so this idea has a
long kind of philosophical
foundation, but basically
you have models, you get,
you introduce new data and
you Revis S based on evidence.
And so one of the questions
which I wanna get into
is like, how general can we
think about this paradigm
of basing inference
currently the paradigms
in which we're doing BA inference,
I'll argue are a lot more constrained than
the most general paradigm
and a lot large part
of what I wanna do
is think about what are the
ways in which we kind of,
what are the ways in which we,
we are to extend the notion
of BA inference to account
for different kinds of
knowledge and different kinds
of information about how the world works.
And so lemme just give you an
example of what I mean here.
So another kind of inference is less
of the kind that
Carl spoke about last
week and more the kind
of logical reason in that we do every day.
And this could be
individual common sense
reasoning all the way up
to kind of the scientific discoveries,
some of the most, some,
some of which are the
most important discoveries
in the universe,
sorry, in the world to this point.
So lemme just give you an example.
So here's Galileo and I'm
sure many of, you know,
Galileo and gal is famous
for, for several things,
but is in particularly famous for discover
in the nature of the moon.
And so Galileo, you know,
in the 16th century,
he looked up at the moon and
he came to this conclusion.
He said, the boundary,
which Devis the part in the shadow
from the shining part does
not extend continuously,
continuously in an ellipse as
would happen to be the case.
If it was sorry, the boundary,
which divides the part in the shadow
from the shining part does
not extend continuously
in an ellipse as would happen
in the case of a
perfectly hysterical body,
but it was marked out
by an irregular uneven
and very wavy line.
So what Galileo was saying here is that
if you look at the moon,
as we were, as we were
doing the next slide,
you can see this wavy line between the,
the light part and the, and the dark part.
And for all about this
is an obvious thing.
But at the time people
thought that the moon
was his perfect sphere.
They thought it was his
perfectly clerical body,
but Galileo looked up
at the moon and he said,
well, it's not, but it wasn't sufficient
for him to just say, it's
not perfectly smooth.
He had to convince his audience.
And so his argument basically goes well,
if it was a perfect sphere,
the line which connects the
light part to the dark part
would be a perfectly
smoother lips, but it's not.
And the, therefore the moon
is not perfectly hysterical.
So this kind of argument,
which is almost like a
proof by contradiction,
if you've done some mathematics
is very common in everyday,
everyday reasoning.
And it's a very important
style of reason because
it led to a revolution in
how we think about the world.
And so how can we build
machines that can do
this kind of logical reasoning,
but at the same time,
it's not purely logical reasoning because
one of the accents here is not very clear,
is there some kind of
formal mathematical basis?
So it's this weird kind of
mixture between logical reasoning
and the messy real world.
And so if you think about
what this looks like in a
slightly more formal sense,
we have some proposition
S which is an immune,
is the perfect sphere.
Some proposition E that the Terminator,
which is the divider between the,
the light and the dark side is an ellipse.
And then we can instruct this kind
of argument assume that it's true.
Assume S it's true.
As in assume, the moon
is the public sphere,
then the Terminator is
ellipse is also true,
but it is not true.
And therefore our con you know,
our Axim is fault.
And so one of the things that
we've been looking at recently
is can we build machines
that can do this kind
of reasoning with kind of real world data?
And this is, you know,
very much just the idea stage.
This is in some sense,
I'm using this kind of talk as an excuse
to think about things that,
which are very speculative,
but our goal is to construct
something like a proof tree.
So you may not be familiar
with this notation,
but this is how people
construct these formal arguments
in mathematics, but instead of a kind
of a normal mathematical logical proof,
we combine that with a generative model.
And so on the one hand,
we have this formal
logical deductive tree.
On the other hand, all of the instances,
all of the elements, all of
the, kind of the variables,
which constitute this logical
tree are themselves generative
are themselves variables in kind of the,
the kind of generative models that
cars spoke about last week.
And this is important because
it's not just efficient
to just, you know, make this
kind of logical argument.
I have to connect it to all of that.
My perceptual vision system, I have,
I have to actually look at the moon
and infer its shape.
I have to actually
use my visual system.
And so what we're trying to
do here in this very early,
early stages is try to bridge
this gap between logical
deductive reasoning and kind of
the more generator generative,
this all kind of Beijing inference
that we're more familiar with.
Okay. So I'm just gonna move on quickly.
So going to algorithms for inference.
So Carl had, this has this slide, and he,
and he's talking about
what is kind of the state of
the art in inference methods.
And I think I agree with Carl
that one of the most exciting
areas here is algorithms are
to combine neural components
with kind of old fashioned
statistical components
to get the best of both world.
And in particular,
you can have kind of neural models,
neuro surrogate models
of a, kind of a hard
to compute conventional model,
or you can have a surrogate
model of a summary statistic,
and there's this really
expanding an explode field
of combinations of neural
models and kind of, you know,
more conventional statistical models.
And just to go back a little bit,
one of the, kind of the key
ideas behind this approach,
which is in Carl's paper is the idea
of automatic differentiation.
So there's many kind of
values in which you would like
to comput in particular,
the kind of the gradient with,
with respect to many different towns,
for example, the likelihood
both in the Euro model
or in a conventional model,
but line all that is a
technology called automatic
differentiation.
And that's what allows you to
get out of a very complicated
model that you can't do by hand.
And so if you think about like,
what kind of thing is
automatic differentiation?
Well, you know,
you can understand it from
the conventional calculus
perspective, but from a
programming language perspective,
and automatic differentiation
is a program transformation.
That is, it takes your program,
the program that you
want to differentiate.
And it turns that into a new program,
which gives you a degree or a gradient
and your ability to do that transformation
relies on having access to the model.
So it's not just a black box model.
I can go in and I can inspect
the source code of the model
and be able to compute these
derivative, which I couldn't,
if it was just a black box model.
And so one of the things I, I,
I work on is not automat differentiation,
but a different kind of
program transformation
for a different need,
but all in service of the same
goal of kind of inference.
And so what is inference in a nutshell,
I think of inference as
generally an inverse problem.
I've got some model, it
gives me some output,
and I wanna know what the input is,
or I wanna know what a
distributional inputs are.
But if that model is a
program simulation program,
then finding the output that would give
some desire.
So finding the input that
would give some desire output,
it's really an Inver program.
I have to run the program backwards.
Now you can do it in indirect ways,
but one of my ideas was
maybe we can tackle this idea
directly, can we actually
just take the program,
try to invert it?
Okay.
So what do I program in version? I mean,
take some pro program
F and its output is Y
and I wanna find X such
that Y is put to F of X.
And so why do we wanna
do this for the reasons
that I just described, but in particular,
we can think of these two examples.
So one is inverse graphics.
So I have,
let's say some three
dimensional scene on the left,
and I have some random
function which takes
that scene and output.
It's a two dimensional image,
and I wanna go backwards
to find what is the three
dimensional scene that
created my observed image.
On the other hand, I might
have a control problem, right?
So I have a robot arm.
I know where I want the hand to be.
What are the joint angles,
which are gonna allow me to get my hand
to that particular point.
So as a software tool,
P conversion take some programs.
So this is ju code.
You don't need to know details,
but the program is some
function on the left.
And we say, well,
give me the inverse of
that program with respect
to some output, right?
So I know what the output of
F is now gimme some input.
And so the goal is to build a system,
which is pretty much
as straightforward in simple as this,
and it just outputs some, some number 42.
Now, how do we do this?
Like, so what, what is the main issue?
So one issue is that
most things are not in,
so how can we have some
notion of an inverse,
which when our forward model is not in,
and so a simple example is just addition.
If I know that F is you put to a plus B
and I know the output is Z.
How do I get the values
of am values of a and B,
which would output to Z equal to five
there's many combinations.
It could be three and two,
four, and one and so on.
And so one of the,
the approaches that I've
developed is called a P inverse.
And so the basic idea is I'm gonna take
my non invertible function,
and there's no inverse to that function
because it's non invertible
and construct this thing,
which we put a P inverse.
And the basic idea behind that is of all
the different combinations
of X and Y with some Z,
I wanna PR parameterize
that space of solutions.
So I want to have a
paramedic representation
of all the different combinations.
And so lemme just show you what that means
in the context of addition,
if F takes us input X
and Y then its inverse
would take us input the
value that should be Z sorry,
and some parameter.
And it returns two values,
one for X and one for Y such
that if I add them together,
I get back the output of the function.
So this is a P
representation of the inverse
of this simple function addition.
Okay.
So most of the time we don't really care
about just addition.
We've got these really complicated models
that we want to invert.
And just to kind of the skip, to skip
to the point, the idea
is that this composes,
so if I've got some complicated program
or some complicated
procedure, for example,
I've got something which
takes into numbers,
adds 'em together within squares them.
I can take every element in that program,
replace it with this P inverse.
So replace addition with
the inverse of edition
or the P inverse of edition replace
the square function as the,
with the P inverse of the square function
and reverse direction of the
order of the computation.
And so the big kind of point
and the is that this autumn
program is an inverse
of the top program.
And so what this means is
that there's a mechanical
transformation.
I can take to some model,
some simulation model,
and literally transform the source code
into an inverse of that model.
Now, you know,
you should be skeptical
because if that were true,
then many, many things would be
which we know to be hard
would, would be automatic.
Right.
But the basic premise,
we can get into some of the details of why
that's difficult in practice.
Let's skip over that.
Okay.
So the last kind of
last area I'm gonna talk
about is knowledge representations.
And so one of the key areas
in which I work is using
programs to represent knowledge, like,
how do we represent
knowledge about the world?
I think programs are
really good representation
because programs,
they have this compositional structure,
you can include continuous parts
discreet parts and simulation
models, the programs,
your networks are programs,
but more generally the space program
is a very rich language.
And in particular, going back to my,
kind of my Galileo
example, if I think about
different conceptions of the universe,
how can you build a system
that could learn like,
or reason like Galileo or
Newton on someone, right?
What are the,
what is the space that represents
all the different kinds
of theories that scientists
have developed over the world?
You know, for example, Newton theory,
I was ma or Capon has had a model
going back further in time.
There's even older models this structure,
which is able to represent this
this very rich notion
of universe models doesn't
seem like it's a continuous
vector space.
It seems like it has a lot more structure.
And so, you know, we
haven't got quite there yet,
but one of the problems that we're working
on is this notion of program
program, Synthes sets,
how do we learn a program from data?
And so lemme just show you
a quick example of that.
Okay.
So here is a kind of an ongoing project,
and this is done with sort
of this background noise.
This is done with Josh Toba,
and most of the work is done
by an undergraduate called.
And the basic idea is that we
have this kind of this game,
like environment on the right hand side.
And this is a program
on the left hand side,
and I can interact with this.
Hopefully let me just try to,
okay.
So, okay.
So it's a little bit
laggy, but you can see
when I click, you know,
these kind of these
purple things come down,
but even that is an inference, right?
It could just be a coincidence.
Somehow.
It seems to be the case that when I click
that causes this pep thing to come down,
and if I press this
blue thing and I click,
you can see that something's
somewhat changed.
Hopefully,
maybe there's some bugs going on, Okay,
this there's a site lag that you can see
this kind of water going down.
Okay.
So the main point here is that this,
this little world is not
particularly interesting.
It's actually just models a water plug,
but it's a very hard thing
for all of modern machine
learning to learn because
you've got these things
when I press this other thing,
nothing changes.
It's only when I make this
further action in the world,
do I see the cha do I
see a change in state?
So when I click now,
I see these other pieces when
I click this black thing,
things should disappear.
Right?
And so what we're trying to do is to build
a kind of a system and a paradigm
of learning where an agent
will interact with this
kind of domain and produce
the entire source code on
the left hand side, right?
In other words, to learn
the model of the dynamics,
just from observant and
interacting in the world.
And this is a very hard problem
because it's not gonna continuous,
it's a very large,
relatively speaking program.
It has a discre discreet structure.
And if you've, you know,
if you've thought about this a little bit,
you can think the space of pro the space
of programs of this
link is enormous, right?
And so how can we figure
out how to synthesize
this program from data?
And so in this example
we can actually do it.
And all of these examples, we can do it,
but this is part of discussion.
So I would end there,
and, but those are the main kind of points
that I wanna focus on,
like notice representations algorithms
for reasoning and modes,
different modes of reasoning.
- Thank you so much, Zenna,
for sort of charting out this landscape
before having asking Kyle
to react a little bit
to the work that you presented,
I'm just burning with curiosity,
given your background in
cognitive science, right.
As well.
So in terms of reasoning,
are there sort of limits and capacities
that are actually hardwired?
Or is this not even a useful question?
I mean, I'd be happy to be told dis abuse
that this is not a question.
- Yeah.
So limits that are, that are hardwired.
I think, I think the
answer is, I don't know,
I don't think anybody knows.
It seems like we've been
able to figure out a lot
about the universe.
People like Karl have,
have helped us help helped
us do that from really
from really sparse observations.
And so I, you know I
would hazard a guess that,
that there is a universality
to our, but to reason,
which is bounded only by kind
of the physical constraints
of the world and our
ability to compute, right.
There's computation.
- And not so much by
neurons and neuro structure
and connections between neurons.
Okay.
- Right.
- Great.
And so anyway, Kyle,
I turn it over to you to
begin your sort of engagement
with what Zenna presented.
- Sure.
Yeah.
Well, I mean it's always
I think I you know,
not that we should look
for something to disagree
on should often not be boring
(both laughing)
in this 'cause I think
we were both excited about
a lot of the same things.
I, and I'm thinking back to my talk,
I didn't really get to say
too much about some of this,
this buzzword of a
probabilistic programming,
which is very related to what's.
But I do think that know this idea
that when you have some story
for how the data came to be,
which is as a physicist you know,
if you're talking to
another physicist you know,
it's a causal story,
it's very natural.
You can,
you can take that story
and you can code it up
into a computer program.
So if you don't feel comfortable
thinking about computer
programs, I think it's,
you're not gonna really miss
anything if you just think
of it as a, the story about
how the data came to be.
And what's nice is that
maybe you could come up
with a computer program
that is very, has a very unnatural story,
but still produces the
same kinds of outputs.
But I think that's not the
spirit of the conversation.
The spirit is much more that
the computer program is
really just a Capturing,
what you think the actual
underlying story is.
And there are so many different ways
that things could play out.
And I think it's really
interesting when you think
about statistical inference
and statistical models,
you know, I introduce the,
these terms of latent variables,
which are random things that happen
in the process of generating
the data that you don't get to see.
And, you know, examples
that I give sometimes
if you think about like the
creation of the solar system,
you know, like how did the moon happen?
Well, maybe some big
thing came and smashed
into the proto earth
and knocked off a big piece.
And there were all these little,
you know early on, it was a
disc and things started to form.
I mean, there's some story that's going
on and you could simulate that
and it would have all sorts of details
about individual rocks
running into each other
and things like that.
We don't get to see any of that.
And when you, if you
actually wanted to simulated
it's just enormously complicated,
like what would be going on.
And especially when you introduce
in the story of like rocks coming,
you know you could imagine like,
did this thing split into
two pieces or three pieces,
or did it just stay together as one piece,
if you wanted to follow
that through the simulation,
you get this just incredibly,
highly space of possibilities
that doesn't look like
it doesn't look like some vector
and like 1000 dimensional vector,
it's this very rich and
like graph structured
thing or something like that.
And so much of statistics
is not really dealt with,
a lot of classical statistics didn't deal
with such structured objects.
And I think one of the things
that's really interesting
right now is we're seeing this kind of
I, it, it's partially computing.
It's partially
it's hard to tell exactly what's going on.
I think to some extent,
I think what what's significant
about machine learning
is that the ambition level
has just jumped so much,
like things that you could
have said, but that you,
everyone have laughed at you.
If you thought you were
gonna actually like
go after it, like,
in some sense what you were
just describing your program
and version, you know?
Sure.
Yeah.
You can do that.
You could have said
that like 10 years ago,
but everyone would be like,
but that's never gonna work.
Like that's, why would you try to do that?
But now all of those things
are on the table, you know?
And there are all,
so many things that are
working at a scale where
you wouldn't expect them to that.
It's just kind of
it's really refreshing
cuz you're going back kind
of to really the first principles
it's like instead of being restricted
by all sorts of constraints that you know,
that make people kind of a have all
these ad hoc workarounds,
people are like kind of
emboldened to go back
to like really first principle approaches
and revisit them.
And it's just surprising that a lot of
that stuff is happening.
So to me, I think the idea
that you're going back really
to like core BA inference kinds of ideas,
but you're the types of
models that you're working
with are just so elaborately complicated
and they map so much more onto the way
that we talk about the world.
It's really exciting.
I dunno.
That's my first reaction, I guess.
(laughs)
- Yeah, I know.
I, so lots of things to
think about and talk about,
so one of the phrases
that you have in you had
in your talk last
week was the idea that simulation models
are causal and models, right?
And you know, this is an intuitive thing
to me and to many people,
part of actually my PhD work,
which I didn't really focus on
here is that taking this idea
literally and saying a lot of the,
kind of the fear, which theory,
which has been developed
in the context of kind
of causal graphical models can be extended
to a richer class of models
in particular program.
So you don't, you know,
the particular formulas
isn't that important,
actually you can have
a much richer formulas,
but there's this,
I think there's this
underlying question maybe
to some degree is
philosophical, which is like,
what is it that makes
simulation models, causal?
Are they necessarily, are
they necessarily causal
or can you think of simulation models,
which aren't causal per se?
Like what is the.
- Zenna aren't they, I mean,
just a quick question to
what is the aren't simulation
models by a construction causal, right?
- Yeah.
- Stay causal.
- That's my question.
I mean I think it is,
but I I'm kind of curious to
- I feel like you start really getting
into lots of interesting subtleties
is where you start to dissect
different notions of causality.
And I kind of pointed it to,
of them in my talk at the beginning
one is, if you're, if
you have a simulation,
that's like a totally
deterministic evolution
of you have some initial state
and you just let it go, you know?
Okay.
It's causal in one sense,
but it's also not causal.
And the other, especially
if it's time reversal
symmetric like the era
of time is confusing
and it's all one object
it's all one thing and so,
when you think about like, I don't know,
space time unfolding
is it evolving through time
or is it just one object
of space time that whole future in past
or all the so you get,
but then there's another sense
if you're, if your operational definition
of causal is that there's
some effective time
ordering and you have states
and, you know, initial
one state goes to another state,
goes to another state
simulations are almost
by definition causal
in that way because they unfold
as the computation plays out.
Right.
But then you can have, you know,
astic components and all sorts of things.
The other thing I think that's interesting
about having this grounding,
a lot of the discussion about causality
in this language is that you,
some of the things that
seem can be confusing.
They just, they they're
revealed in a very precise way.
So for instance I could take
if I wanted to in the language of like
Uur causality,
if I want to intervene
and go set some value
to something like,
imagine I have a particle and it has some,
it has some energy and some
momentum and some mass,
like, what if I just
want to move its energy?
Like that breaks some condition that
that there's some relationship
that would no normally be there.
And that's like not an
admissible kind of intervention.
Right.
And if you actually
try to do this in code,
like it's kind of weird,
depending on how you wrote your code.
Maybe it will continue to proceed,
but you'll just get nonsense out.
Or maybe it will,
it will have a, you know,
segmentation fault
because like at some point
it assumes that this
condition is satisfied
so you get it's just kind of,
it lays bare a few of the
subtleties around causality,
which I think often are
discussed and very like,
not to there's anything
wrong with pH speed,
but in a philosophical
language where I think it,
it can be hard to latch onto, but there,
it can be kind of grounded
in a very concrete term
where you can separate out
in know slightly different
notions in a very, yeah.
- In a clear way in so 100%.
So in our,
we have this paper and it's
called omega a language
for counter function reason.
And the point of this paper
is to define what it means to perform
an intervention on a general program.
And one of the questions that arises
is exactly what you just said.
Like, what if you do some intervention,
which breaks the
semantics of your program?
Like it makes it invalid.
Like, is there some,
is there some scope in
which you just say, well,
that's not allowed?
Or do you just allow it
and see what happens?
And then the more you think about it,
the more you get into
this question of like,
what is an intervention
in the first place?
Is it just some arbitrary?
You know, so in a common
literature and intervention is
the reassignment or some node
to some new value, right.
But when you go to more expressive models,
that doesn't seem deficient.
And so is there some underlying
more fundamental logic,
which is less tied to one
particular representation
of a causal model,
which would say this is a
valid intervention or not.
- Right.
- And then going to your
I guess your point you made earlier,
if you think about kind of
these more abstract models.
So like,
let's say I've got some low
level complex simulation model,
like say a physics simulation,
but I wanna be able to
say like some high level
intervention, like what if, I don't know,
like what if I threw
the ball or something,
what's the right.
Like,
how do those high level
interventions interact
with kind of the low level
microscopic model I think is,
is another related question.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I I'll pick up on a comment
that I see in the chat.
So Jeremy Zucker said,
simulations don't need to unfold in time.
One could specify constraints
among all the variables,
add an objective and treat
the entire simulation
as an optimization problem.
I mean I don't want to get
into the weeds too much.
I think that, you know,
I think the link language
that I had used was
that there's some, some
effective notion of time,
meaning that like, literally
as the computation evolves.
So like when you compile
the program and you run it,
like it is, there is a serial
operation that's happening.
So that there's some
effective notion of time there
that might not have anything
to do with like time, like,
as we think of it and on
our watch or something.
And that's kind of a,
that example is kind of
interesting because I think
and I tried to sort of couch my,
my statement earlier that
you can have a simulation
that produces kind of the right output,
but that the way that it unfolds the story
that it tells might have nothing
to do with how anyone
thinks the world works.
Right.
So in that sense, it's totally,
anti-coal from like a
physical point of view
it's not like a plausible
scenario for how it actually came
to be, but as an operational definition
of what do I mean by causal?
Like, it you could use that,
like define it and like
give it a new name if you want
computational causality
or something like that.
You know, it's some
very well defined notion
of causality that it,
so even in that situation,
that example if it's an
optimization problem,
like solving the
optimization problem would
be like the causal model for the data,
which is very unsatisfying from the point
of view of a physical a story, but may,
but totally operationally well defined,
but it also makes you
think, well, actually,
well, maybe not maybe, you know,
like classical mechanics is expressed
as can be expressed as oil
Laron optimization problems,
you know, maybe somehow that's actually
how the universe is
implement things who knows.
Right.
You know, but it, I think that's part of,
what's interesting about describing it
that way is that, I don't know,
it allows you to ask some
pretty weird philosophical
questions while still grounding
it in a very concrete,
actionable, you know, set
of definitions, you know?
- Right.
And it seems like it places the burden
on the modeler to ensure that
the causality in the
world that they care about
is mirrored in this notion
of computational causality,
which you use to construct your model,
which is kind of a weird,
but maybe necessary thing.
Right?
- Yeah.
Or at least it's a route at a don't know
necessary who knows,
but like it's a way to
frame the discussion
that also I think, and (indistinct).
- That's what I meant when
I say you have to put it
in by hand, right.
That there's a mapping
that you do on news.
- Yeah.
And I made some references to this kind
of normative discussion
and things like that.
I think that's what what's
a little bit interesting
is if you want,
wanna then talk about causal
inference from the point
of view of reasoning and our
there's a part which is
about it being a useful thing
to do that allows us to learn efficiently
from limited amounts of data.
Right.
And so there, the, when you
start to frame it that way,
you can also,
it makes it a little bit
easier to talk about,
you know,
sample complexity of learning algorithms
and these kinds of things.
And sometimes you can,
you can make some pretty strong statements
like they're not just
like the best algorithm
that I've thought of today.
I mean, you can kind of like show, like,
there's no way you're going
to learn this without like
exponentially more data
than if you thought
about it in a different right.
You know, so, and I think
those are, those are relevant.
You know I think that complex,
those complexity issues,
I don't think are just like, like,
oh, a matter of computation,
they're not like fundamental.
I think those things usually
are probably something strong
signs of something that's
actually much more fundamental,
you know?
So I do have a question for,
I guess is like the, so you,
you talked about kind of this inverting
the programs and things like,
and I think that's super cool.
And I think, yeah, this whole
like what that example
probabilistic programming,
automatic differentiation, many other
that are things that are this
kind of high level program
transformation are really
interesting set of ideas
to think about what I'm,
but you also gave this example about
the argument that the moon
is not perfectly smooth,
where it's super very fast and loose type
of (laughs) argument.
And when I think about, I don't know,
like how I think about like,
what's going on say at the
LHC when something strange
is happening in the data,
and I wanna try to figure it out
it's definitely in the
fast and loose category.
I'm not like iteratively inverting
my mental model for like how the low level
particle interactions
happened or something.
So I'm curious since this is squarely.
- Oh, Kyle, I just wanna
little bit of a clarification.
So what do you mean by fast and loose?
Are you talking about
eliminative reasoning or.
- Oh, well, this example about arguing
that the Terminator of the moon is wiggly,
you know, it had a logical element,
but at the same time,
it's sort of based on
there's an observational component
and it's not really well,
I don't know.
I mean, I guess all, a lot of other,
maybe other examples
of human reasoning like
that they were given at the beginning,
like the car accident
and the weather and stuff like that.
It's not I don't think,
well, I don't know.
I don't feel like humans
are doing some kind
of logical reasoning at that level as kind
of some approximate, I mean, they're
they manipulating high level
sense of reasoning in that way,
but it's not so formal.
And once you get into something
that's more complicated
where that you get this explosion
of possible paths that
the inverse of that problem is
has an explosion of possibilities.
I don't feel like we're like keeping track
of all the possibilities that some,
somehow we have some effective way of.
- Hindering.
- Yeah.
Of kind of playing out entire,
like, not individual scenarios,
but like whole classes
of scenarios that kind
of are placeholders for
distributions of possibilities.
And we manipulate them
just very efficiently.
And we were able to like,
pick the right abstraction to do that.
And to me, that's, it's magic.
I don't know, like.
(Kyle laughs)
- Yeah.
I mean,
I wonder if that's
because we have some kind
of mechanism to eliminate
possibilities, right.
So that the, or we reduce
the complexity basically,
as you're saying, right.
Somehow we are able to
reduce the complexity
of possibilities in human reasoning.
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- So, but did you have a
specific question or just,
just on general, I'm curious.
- I mean I just felt like
the two different things
were the two things you
showed were in some sense
they have the same underlying drive,
but they're kind of opposite extremes.
Like one is a very,
you know, like you're
making this reasoning.
I don't think people are going
through all these possibilities.
And then the other example
was this kind of a program
a transformation which is
gonna have this explosion
of possibilities.
Right.
And so.
- Right, right.
Yeah.
So I think, you know,
thinking about what I call this kind
of approximate, logical reasoning,
or it's not,
it's not quite formalized yet.
I think that the goal there
is to is to characterize
what I think we would we do all the time.
Right.
So maybe if you,
I don't know if you went
home and the window was open,
you might be like,
well my partner must be here.
Otherwise it wouldn't be open.
Right.
And so we do this kind
of thing all the time.
So when you come to that conclusion,
are you doing like a massive simulation
of all the possible walls?
Right.
But it's so,
I don't think it's just about efficiency.
It's a different form of
reasoning in the same way
that producing a mathematical
proof is from sampling.
Right.
It's not just like a
different kind of algorithm.
It's a different nature, right?
Yeah.
Mathematical proof has this kind
of logical deductive structure, right.
This tree structure,
which can be formalized
in many different ways,
but I don't think that has
been kind of adapted to,
you know, common sense scenarios.
And so part of what I wanna do to,
to try to do is to think
about like, what is that?
Because it seems like pretty fundamental,
like way prior to Galileo.
There were many people
who came to the conclusion
that the moon was mountainous
through this kind of logical,
informal, deductive reasoning
back to Aristo states.
And so it seems to allow us to come
to insights way beyond our
observational kind of capacity,
but it's I, you know
what it is I don't know,
but I just feel like there's a whole,
and part of what I'm trying
to convey here is that aside
from the current paradigms
of reason and inference,
which paramedic inversion
is part of this kind
of the second thing,
I think there's just many
more interesting modes
of reasoning.
So to give you another example,
one thing I think about
a lot is this notion
of actual causality.
So going back a little bit
to this notion of causality,
simple question, right.
Did a cause B for example, like
did I threw a rock, it hit
a window and it smashed,
did my throne of the rock
was the window to smash.
Right.
It sounds quite simple
how can you make a machine
do that kind of reason?
And it turns out that it's
incredibly hard, right?
It seems simple.
Like he might say,
well, like had I not thrown,
then the window wouldn't have smashed.
That sounds like a reasonable thing,
but it turns out that breaks
down in many different ways,
because like, what if something,
something else would've
caused it to crash any
to crash anyway.
And so this is a basic question,
which we don't have the definitions right.
About being, let alone
the algorithm don't have
the right definitions
and what it points to.
The more I think about this is the,
like this notion of causality
as almost like a epistemic question.
Like when I think about causality,
is it really about the underlying world?
Or is it more just about
human minds, right.
Like, you know, not is the
causality part of the world,
or is it part of our mind?
And so is our hope to get these kind
of pristine notions of
causality, a fool errand,
because fun fundamentally
the kind of messy concepts,
or is it more this kind
of metaphysical thing,
which a little bit like probity
where there is this underlying
pristine theory, we just
have to discover it,
but we haven't, we haven't got there yet.
So maybe that's a little bit abstract,
but that's kind of how I,
how I've been thinking about it recently.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
And I think it's interesting.
I mean, definitely it's yeah.
I mean the, well what's to say, I mean,
it goes back a little bit to, I mean,
this idea that you're
trying to come up with,
like PO plausible explanations
for something, right.
I think points a lot to this idea
that you have you don't,
it's not that you're
just running some program
that was already for you.
You're kind of constructing
the program as you go,
like could this have been the explanation?
And if so,
then you can kind of mentally
simulate what would happen
and the consequences of that thing,
but to do so you kind of have
a vocabulary of different or ontology
of different kinds of
things and how they can,
how you can compose them.
And you know, a lot of
programs are kind of,
they're just more rigid
versions of the same thing,
where the types of stories
it's sort of a choose your own adventure,
but it's a very,
very structured here.
You kind of like on the fly,
I get to add things.
And I think, you know that in my talk,
I mentioned a little bit
about hypothesis generation
and stuff.
I was trying to contrast against
if you just think about like
a lot of kind of black box
machine learning algorithms
that maybe can solve like the
particular scientific tasks
that you're on right now,
better than anything else on the market,
that's maybe that's true,
but like, what do you do next?
Right.
You know, like if you, you know,
you test that particular
theory at high accuracy
and you get the most out of
your data and that's great,
but like now,
now what experiments should you do?
Right?
Like if you somehow can't introspect,
like if or something goes wrong,
like the data does not
look like you expected
from your theory, like what do you do?
You know?
And the human doing it,
even though maybe it's not squeezing
everything out of the data,
like it has this
explainability component to it,
because the way the data is
being analyzed is composed
of a bunch of things that you understand,
and then you can go inspect it
every little step of the way.
And if anywhere in there
you can isolate where things
went wrong or were unexpected.
And then that motivates
generating new hypotheses,
which are new stories that might explain
why it went differently.
And I think that's absolutely
key to how science is.
I know it,
and people that I know that, that do it
how they would approach
such a problem, you know?
And so, and what's good
is that yeah, sure.
It looks different than
kind of the current AI,
but it's actually,
it's adjacent to stuff that's happening.
I mean, you're doing it,
I'm doing some stuff,
so it's not like some radical like,
oh, we're on the wrong path.
It's like right now,
we're figuring out how to do
these hybrid it's between,
you know, probabilistic
programming that have
take advantages of the powerful parts
of current deep learning things
and mix all this stuff together.
So I, you know, there are
a lot of people that are,
that say, oh, we're on the
wrong path or whatever.
But I feel like actually these
are starting to come together
in a way that looks very exciting.
And I think, yeah,
I don't know.
- Yeah.
And one of the things that
I think is interesting,
and I think it was in one of
your charts to some degree,
right? Is
this notion that the scientific process
is a lot more expansive than often the,
kind of the more narrow
view that we give it
in other words, like if you,
if you're experimented in
or you got some strains
of observations,
you might invent a new
in entirely new theory,
form of mathematics, right?
It's not just, you know,
like a, a constrained action space.
You can really change.
And the fundamentals,
at least like historically
humans have like,
you're building upon this
like massive foundation.
And so I'm really interested said like,
how do we, like all of these things
that we take for granted when
by the time we bought a
modern machine learning tool
we've already taken for
granted calculus and
what are the objects that we care about?
All of that is kind of
given by the humans.
But if we wanna build
machines that can do that part
of the process, too, what do we have to,
what do we have to give them?
One question I wanna
to ask was around this
this notion of like
modeling and representations
of knowledge, you have the term,
this term collaborative modeling,
which I think is great.
I wish I invented it, but
I'll certainly steal it.
What do you think are the
kind of the key components
of building a collaborative
model at scale?
Like how how I,
I'm very curious to like your
interpretation of this phrase,
but I particularly, I'm curious,
like what are the kind of the barriers,
which prevent like me as
let's say an epidemiologist
and somebody else.
So I don't know, like a climate scientist
from kind of getting together
and building some model,
which takes into account all
of these different components
in some coherent and cohesive way.
- Yeah.
Wow.
That, yeah, that's it, that's a great,
I like how you threw it back at me.
(Kyle laughs)
Yeah.
Well, I think there's a part which
when I first like coin that term,
I, it was applied to a pretty
narrow set of problems,
which was really kind of
how do you do statistical
modeling kind of,
really in the context of sort of
like LHC where there's lots of different
lots of different data sources
or views of larger data set
that things are related in various ways.
You want to previously,
it was very top down and
rigid sort of structure
to be able to bring those things together.
And it didn't scale.
Well, and then at some point
we've figured out a way,
like, to be able to let people kind
of work in a more decoupled way,
understand their part of the problem,
let their be the experts
and their problem,
figure out how they want to think about it
and parameterize it,
but still maintain the ability
to bring them all together
in a kind of co and do some
coherent inference in the end.
And that was like a
and once we introduced,
there was just some
underlying technology really
that the kind of in terms of model sharing
and interfaces and things like that
and once we got that part,
right there was just then this
like literally exponential
explosion of complexity,
which was, it was amazing to watch.
And it was kind of scary also because like
computationally,
everything became very hard very quickly.
And so we had to figure
out how to keep up.
But what I do think is kind of interesting
and it's a little bit
more on the meta side,
is that in this when we went to
started working on these like simulation
based inference problems,
what's I love about that is
that it's really like a lingo
franca for methodological
experts and domain experts
to be able to really
effectively collaborate
because there's somehow you,
you encapsulate a lot of
detail about your problem
and you expose some way
of talking about it, like,
but literally through interfaces
that methodological
people can work with where
if they don't need to know the details,
they can kind of be shielded from it.
But it, but you're not like you're not,
you're not losing a lot
of the real complexity of
what's going on inside there.
And I think that that it's just
true that we I'm now able
to have conversations
with neuroscientists
and cosmologists and epidemiologists
and bio geneticists and stuff at a level
that I've never been able to have before.
And so, and then, and I actually,
it's also been way for me to understand
their problem much more efficiently,
like even the details of their problem,
because like the,
on the onboarding of
that is really useful,
but there's a part which is it's really
actually much more on the
like software engineering
interface level,
which allows you to actually build models
and do composition composition.
Like you would want that,
but it's very actionable in that sense,
but it also kind of pays off in a way
that you would hope a
bigger, a bigger kind of
more ambitious answer to
your question that this is
something that sounds
like as lowly as like
good interfaces or something.
But it actually,
I think sort of starts to realize that
and it's really compelling idea because
if you think about COVID simulations,
like our epidemiology the simplest ones,
or you just have a,
some uniform population,
it doesn't even necessarily
exist spatially.
It's just like,
there's some number of people,
some number of people will have it.
There's some chance that
they're gonna give them and then you get
these like differential equations,
but those differential
equations are really like all
averages of something they're not,
they don't look like have
some underlying spasticity
and they don't like,
now let's say I want to actually think
of it as actual people.
And they actually live in actual cities
and I know where they are.
Like, I mean, it can you know,
it can be scary sounding,
but I mean, if you just,
in terms of the richness
of the model, like
you can just, you can, well this
group of people in this
neighborhood behave
a little bit differently
you got like the 20 somethings over here
and they've got the
other people over here,
they have different patterns,
they interact differently with each other,
and you can definitely see
the story about how you would
actually build up such a model
where people that know about
the different pieces
contribute in some much more
collaborative way.
And that's like that's exciting.
I mean, you have to be careful,
(Kyle laughs) but...
- I mean, yeah.
I think like, as I've thought
about this, more, like,
it seems like one key thing
is, as you just said, like,
how do you have these entities who are,
which are shared between different groups.
So one model is talking about people,
populations of people,
the other model is talking about people
at a more fine gray level.
But as humans, we just gotta communicate
and say, Hey, both that's about people.
Or maybe we use a variable name
to indicate that's a person.
Right.
But it seems like a lot of them knowledge
that we have in our
about the world is not,
is not actually in the
model representation.
It remains in our heads.
And then we communicate
with each other to tell us,
you know, what that means.
Right.
But it seems like if you
wanna be able to build
systems that can really
reason they're gonna have to,
in some sense, represent the entire stack.
So all the way down it's not just
like a, an abstract variable,
but this really represents
a human in some sense.
- Right.
I mean, it's a lot of
implicit knowledge, right.
That is brought to bear.
- Right.
Right.
And then the second thing is like,
if you have different people
contributing different models,
which may be inconsistent, right.
You may, you need some
way to integrate that
that knowledge together, right?
- Yeah.
- Is there a kind of a,
a sound way to do that?
Or is it more like a heuristic
approach that we, but.
(indistinct)
- I mean,
there may be instances where
you not only need to integrate,
but you may need to arbitrate right.
Between two.
- Yeah.
- I looking at the questions
to say, but yeah, no,
I think it's, well
the last thing, I mean
I just TA tag on that this whole story
also is a natural path to being able
to try to do the thing where
you have the different
hierarchies of representations.
You know, if you can figure out some way
of having this kind of ontology
and almost like a type
system over the different
kinds of entities
you can certainly start to make things
that are hierarchical
or some mini to many,
or like here's an
alternate way of thinking
about the problem with a
totally different set of things,
you know?
And they you may just switch
from one modeling paradigm
to another modeling paradigm.
You know,
they might not be able to
mix them, but for one task,
one is appropriate and the
other one's the other one's
appropriate, or you know who knows,
or be able to telescope
in and out and refine
the detail if you need it.
And if not enjoy
the benefits (laughs) of
working at a high level.
But yeah, if you have
inconsistencies and stuff,
I think that's which is certainly real.
I don't, I'm guessing things get to
a little bit messy at that
point there's, (Kyle laughs)
- (indistinct) somewhat deeper point.
So going to the example
you had in your talk
with the machine, the
kind of the bean machine
where you had.
- [Kyle] Right.
- You know, produce this, like
nonconventional distribution.
And as you said, like, as a
determined, it's a process,
but you can think of it sarcastically.
And so I guess the question is like
I'm kind of coming from
the more subjective base
perspective,
which is that when I think
of that as a distribution,
that's more like my kind of belief right.
About it, about its outcome.
And so when we go to
languages or representations
for problematic knowledge,
there's a kind of a subject
there's a, like a hidden subject.
Right.
You know, if I say an X to
some normal distribution,
maybe there's like a hidden
extension to that phrase,
which is like X is a normal
distribution believed by me.
And so if we want to integrate
lots of different knowledge
from lots of different sources,
maybe we need an explicit
representation of where kind of
the Providence or the
sources of these beliefs.
So that if X is a normal
belief by person X and Y
is the X is I don't know,
a be distribution believed by
person, Y there's some way,
which we can take kind of the
relative relative like creds
of these two individuals
to say, well, okay.
- Right.
- I'm gonna integrate
that in some consistent.
So maybe that's a long
way of saying that maybe
an integral part of kind of a sound way
to integrate knowledge is to make
explicit the notion of subjectivity
in our protic models.
I that's a kinda a...
- Yeah, no, I think I mean
I alluded briefly to
the, in particle physics.
It's one of the kind
of last holdouts where
Basian inference is not
fully embraced, but.
- Right.
- It's partially because when you talk,
start talking about things
like the pro distribution
on some fundamental constant of nature,
or like, does this fundamental
particle exist or not,
or does the symmetry of nature exist?
You know, is that,
does nature have that symmetry or not?
Like you can't base it on data.
So you really have to embrace
the subjective version
of that,
but there is not an agreement
among physicists, right.
If there was like some wide agreement,
then maybe no one would care.
But if, when you have wildly different
subjective priors associated
to different scenarios, like
what do you do operationally?
Right.
You know, it's tricky.
I think that it, well this would
be an entire other hour discussion,
but I think there there's a
part which is maybe worth saying
is that oftentimes we couch a lot of this
and like BA inference.
And a lot of these things is somehow like,
there's like a rational or
optimal way of doing it.
And that like the sound
way kind of presumes that,
like we should be trying
to do something that's like
consistent or whatever.
There there's a, another view,
which is that
we're not really optimizing anything.
We're not like,
you know, we just, we're
just doing, (laughs)
and there's like,
there's kind of dynamics, you know?
And especially when you think about like
a very heterogeneous group of
people that have heterogeneous
access to different pieces of information,
and then you just think about behavior
it's not necessarily
maybe in some cases it,
its well modeled by something
that looks like some bays
optimal something, but
in many other cases,
maybe it's just like I was
hungry and that's why I didn't,
(laugh) and so then you
get into a question,
what are you, what exactly
are you trying to describe?
Are you trying to,
are you trying to be
descriptive or prescriptive
and a whole story? You know.
- So Zenna is a question
for you in the chat.
If everything in the
ontology stack should be up
for evolution, can
anything pristine at all,
as in your characterization
of probability theory remain
and to Kyle,
can your statement that the
particle physics simulators
already a wide variety of
alternative theories be taken
literally enough to mine it for
grammar of nearby the space?
I guess the expansion
of permitted theories.
Interesting question.
Zenna you have a go first yeah.
- I'm try to (indistinct) yeah.
I think I would like some clarification,
but maybe I'll make a guess
exactly what you mean by Anne.
- I'm not sure how the word
evolution is being used there.
- Yeah.
I was gonna say Buoyant,
could you clarify and type
in the Q a I guess really?
What do you mean by evolution?
- I can respond to the other part if,
if you want to have time or maybe he wants
to hear the answer and that's not fair.
(Kyle laughs)
- Go ahead.
- Yeah.
I guess I'd say that
I had made the comment last week that
there's a part where when
you're doing simulation based
inference, it seems like, well,
how do you learn anything new?
Because you already have
it in your simulator
and it that seems reasonable.
And I tried to re reframe
that is that like,
whenever you're doing inference,
it's kind of in the context
of some model, right?
So like if the,
to the extent that in inference
looks like this inverse
problem, it's an inverse of something.
And so like that there's
a model there kind of
to start the discussion.
So the, so in the case
of particle physics model
is not like the standard
model of particle physics,
which is a specific theory is,
is like one point in the
space of possible theories
that can all be expressed
in the language of whatever
quantum field theory.
And so that language of
quantum field theory allows you
to express all sorts of other
possible scenarios and
universes that can be described.
And for the most part
I think most professional
physicists feel like essentially
anything that looks remotely like the
his anything like our
universe is gonna be expressed
in that language.
So in that sense it's very,
it's a very expressive one.
And if you wanted to work
outside that language
you really, everything
starts to kind of like,
you really have to revisit
everything, you know?
- And,(indistinct) and yeah.
- And so in terms of mining,
mining it for the grammar
of nearby theory space,
I mean, in some sense
it depends a little bit
on how you mean it,
but I think in many senses, absolutely.
Yes.
There's a very systematic
approach for kind of how to
like if you go to some theory
how to expand around it
in a nice way and to the grammar
is like really very explicit.
And it's one of the things actually,
another one of Josh 10 and
bounds, former students,
Brendan lake who's here at NYU.
He and I have of had
various discussions about
this kind of,
can we operationalize like rediscovering
the standard model where, but where you,
you operate in this kind
of grammar of theories
that's restricted and
quantum field theory,
and it would be computationally expensive,
but I think you absolutely could.
And the part that's a little on one side,
it sounds super ambitious on another.
It is,
it's kind of so clear how
you would go about doing it,
that it almost is like,
is it worth the worth
the effort like it would,
(laughs)
so it would be great to
do it and to say like,
here's an automated algorithm
that like basically went
through the space of theories
and some structured way
and basically came upon
the standard model
and said, this is it.
And I don't have any X
evidence for anything beyond it.
And it would be fun to
do, but I think it's kind
of in another sense,
it's kind of clear how you would proceed.
- Right.
So Zenna, there's a bit of a
clarification from Bouyant.
- Yeah.
Did you see that?
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
So yeah.
Think I have better
sense of this question.
So it going back to what
talking about earlier,
which is that scientists
change the foundations,
both the mathematical
foundations and the ontologies,
which we use in various different ways.
And so I think Bouyant your
question is if you permit that,
then you know,
how do you prevent your kind of your house
from just like crumbling
on how and how do you
it seems like if there's no
kind of stable foundation,
then anything goes, maybe
that's my interpretation
of this question and the answer.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think maybe when we think about
a theoretical framework,
maybe think thinking about
it less as being like true
or not true is it's more
like useful or not useful.
And I think if we maybe go a little bit
to what you said earlier,
Kyle, like what is our,
if we have some kind of goal,
which maybe to predict the future,
which maybe to, I make,
provide inferences,
we can think about all
the layers below as like
either in service of that or not.
And so I think provided
that there is some kind
of foundational not foundation.
There is some kind of external objective.
I think we can be flexible
with these foundations
as long as they're in service
and to your kind of example,
like property theory is pristine.
No, I think it's,
it's a pristine model of
like rational thought,
which is really dependent on agents.
Like, I think it would
be hard maybe maybe,
maybe this is where car might disagree,
(laughs)
but I think it might be hard to
kind of justify prob theory
as being like uniquely good
in the absence of rational agents.
But that is kind of maybe
a controversial claim,
but yeah, I'll leave it that.
- And I guess there is another question
about counterfactuals,
I guess, the references to
you know there was this book by,
at this work by David
Deutche and Kiara Mar Marto,
the science of can.
And can't,
I remember reading that a
physicist joining through
the land of counterfactuals.
I think the question here is
counterfactuals can serve as
an important thinking tool,
right?
In the deeper expert of causal connections
and alternate scenarios.
And so the question is that
they argue that describing physical laws
in terms of counterfactual tasks,
they generate and they
counter possible tasks
that cannot be generated.
And the question is,
is this kind of reasoning
seems very similar
to the way that Galileo was able
to infer the non smoothness
of the lunar surface.
Right?
- Yeah.
There is something very
counteract about you, right?
It's this, this kind of
if this were true, right.
The moment you have a
wood in your sentence,
kind of in this counterfactual.
- Yeah.
- Counter factual regime.
And so it,
it does seem that this
kind of reason both touches
own counter factories and
also this kind of proof
by contradiction style reason.
Maybe those two things are equivalent
in some fundamental way.
I kind, I'm not certain yet, but I yeah.
I think it's interesting, again,
going back to this
already question of like,
what, like,
what is the status of these
kinds of statements, right.
If I make a counter
factual statement, does
is that something that's true
or false or I, or is it just...
- Yeah.
I was just gonna say
it's one festival, right?
I mean, I'm kind of
uncomfortable in a way.
I mean, they're tricky.
Counterfactuals are quite tricky, right.
Because they're not testable.
And so what is that,
for example, in science,
I've never quite understood
what sort of their utility is.
- But. (indistinct)
- It right in that.
- But even, I guess, I guess what the,
what lies at the foundation
of a valid factual,
I think is the validity of
your model in the world, right.
If you have a correct
model, then in some sense,
your account of factuals are
correct by by construction.
And so even though they're not testable,
there might be a sense in which
they can be correct or not.
Correct.
Which gets pushed down to the question of,
is your model correct? Or not correct,
but that becomes com because, you know.
- So, I mean, I was thinking of
the kinds of examples they use.
Right.
I mean, I remember one, I
think there's something like
you know, the possibility
of building a steam engine,
which existed long before the
first one was actually built.
- Right.
- Something they give as an
example of a counterfactual.
Right.
And I mean, so,
and this is so as it exists
in the domain of the possible,
and its functioning does
not violate the principle
of conservation of energy
and whereas the sort of
counterfactual property
imposed by the laws of physics
that is that you cannot, for example,
build up a perpetual motion machine.
Right.
I mean, so these are the sort
of ways in which they use it.
So, I mean,
it's a way to permit
ourselves to sort of entertain
the idea of possible worlds.
Right?
- Right.
Right.
- Or alternate universes
that are like variants
of our current realities.
I mean, that's where I get stuck and say,
well it's not testable, so.
- Right
I sort of article
recently, which was trying,
it's like a logical
philosophical article trying
to give a formal definition
of what a law is.
- [Priya] Right.
- And the way they're
trying to do it is say,
well, it kind of must remain
true under any counterfactual
scenario.
Right.
So there's a difference between saying
I haven't done this yet
versus this is impossible,
which is quite a hard
distinction to actually anyway,
how do you have thoughts?
- Yeah.
Well, I think, I mean,
one of them is that, yeah.
I think that on the
counterfactual, it makes sense,
you know, when, coupled with a model,
because like, then you can
basically with that model,
you can sort of simulate other scenarios.
Right.
And it's not testable in the sense
that you can't like literally with that
go back and change the thing that,
that happened a different way.
So for that particular instance,
yes, it's not testable,
but it it's testable within the,
within the model and it
has consequences, you know?
And so like like, so
then you, so then you,
if you think of it in more
of a decision theory way,
like you're going to use your model answer
ask the question, what if I
had done blah, blah, blah,
you know, simulate or something,
reach some conclusion.
And based on that,
you're now going to take some
informed action in the future.
You know, if your model is bad,
then you, you may end up
walking off your cliff
or doing something bad.
You know, if your model is good, then it,
it may help guide you to see so, yeah.
So in that sense it has consequences,
but it's maybe not testable
in a very strict way.
Also,
if you think you can somehow
like re prepare an equivalent
or something like that,
and then sort of do it again,
and you have some notion of
exchange ability then, but.
- It sounds like if you
are able to simulate it,
then it's testable in that way.
Right.
In the way that simulations allow test.
- Yeah.
And then but the other example where
if you can somehow re prepare the,
a similar or initial state and do it again
with the, you know, with the opposite
with a different, the
counterfactual scenario
then it that's effectively simulating,
you're just using actual the actual world
to do the simulations.
So but it still involves a model
in the sense that you you're saying,
when you say that,
I think this initial state is,
is the same as the previous initial state.
Right.
You know, like how do you
know that that's true.
Right.
You know,
that's effectively a model
in the sense that you,
you think that whatever you
did to prepare this initial
state is like equivalent
and then so you, yeah.
So I but in both cases,
whether it's SIM related
or it's like actually like
in a lab and doing something,
you're still bringing some
assumptions to the table
and you look to see what happens.
You reach some conclusion and then
you act accordingly.
And if you're wrong if the, if you,
your process of preparing
the same initial state,
it actually didn't take into account like
the temperature in the room,
and that's important,
then you'll reach the
wrong conclusion and your,
your car is not gonna.
work Whatever.
- I guess a lot of my skepticism
of counteract was really,
I have to confess right.
Comes out of a bias is that this relates
this is sort of an offshoot
of this idea of multiverses
that people are constant with
this idea that the multiverse
there's an infinite number
of possible universes.
And it has obviously
broad explanatory scope,
so it's kind of attractive.
And, but nothing you know,
about the multiverse is really testable.
Right.
So I think that is where I,
that's where my sort of notion that
this is not so testable, right.
Is that, you know.
- Had a multiverse talk
in the series that.
- Right.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
So I mean I and I always get stuck right.
When we think of,
when I try to put the
kinds of conceptual things
that you both talked about and in sort
of the multiverse frame.
Right.
So, you know,
if the universe in principle
you can imagine universe
is for which, you know,
the Newton's love gravitation takes
on a completely different form from ours.
Right.
And, or a UN multiverse in which
gravity may not even exist.
Right.
So how would you discriminate
between those universes
where Newton's law nearly
takes a different form,
but one in which, you know,
gravity at all doesn't exist,
therefore that law doesn't exist anyway.
So I think I'm, it,
it's a different rabbit
hole that we don't,
we don't wanna go down.
And there's a question that
somebody has asked Zenna that,
do you have a reference for
the article that you just
mentioned about the discussion of laws?
Like what the relationship between a law
and the counterfactual
that it, or is valid.
- If you email me,
I can find it somewhere
in my internet history.
I do have another question if you,
if you have time still for.
- Yeah, of course.
Yes.
Yeah, please.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
So this notion of like
abstraction or different models
at different levels of fidelity has,
has come up a few different times.
And I think as maybe
you indicated this also,
it seems integrated into
this other question of like,
how do you have different,
how do this kind of collaborative,
collaborative modeling?
So an example that I used to
say when Obama was president,
I would say like suppose
somebody asked me,
I suppose I asked you like,
how tall is Malia Obama?
This is a kind of a very
common, not common question,
but a very ordinary question.
Right?
And so most people don't know the answer,
but they can make a guess, right.
They can say, well, you
know, maybe, you know,
her father was a president and presidents
are kind of typically tall.
So maybe she's this tall or
or I know she's a woman maybe she's
and so all these different
kind of sources of information,
maybe, you know,
her ethnic background that
will come to integrate
into your conclusion.
And so going to my question,
when I think about how do we build kind
of very large collaborative models,
I can think of almost like a multiverse
of different models that are,
that are connected together.
It seems that one integral
part must be the notion
of different models being more
or less abstract than another,
to give another example.
When I think about something
as simple as a light switch,
right?
If I understand the light switch as just,
you know, some binary
model press the light.
If the light comes on at another level
I studied the electronic
engineer and as an undergraduate,
I understand the electric
circuitry behind it.
Another level, I'm just a human.
So I understand the physical the physical,
actual geometry of lights switch.
I have all of these
different forms of knowledge
and they all influence how I
interact with the light switch.
So if it doesn't work right,
my light switch doesn't turn on.
It could be because the
electronics are broken.
It could be,
'cause the London power station is down.
It could be because the mechanical switch
is broken and I'll choose the
right level appropriately,
or at least I'll try to.
And so going to your
simulation based models
and simulation based inference,
do you have an intuition
about how we can build
representations or models,
which can capture these
different levels of abstraction
or these different perspectives or these
different sources of
knowledge in a way again,
which is coherent.
And is that a different question
to this collaborative question?
So one question, but yeah.
- I mean, that's a topic
that I'm very interested in
and sort of wanting to
work what I'm working on,
but in various levels.
So, I mean, part of it is, I think
also just asking some
easier questions at first,
which with that, those kinds of questions,
a goal, but you even get
into the situation of
say that you already are
kind of handed the different,
you know, models at, at
different abstraction levels.
And, also you probably want
to prepare for the fact
that the ones that are
at like a higher level
of abstraction maybe are
not quite as accurate.
Right.
So how do you incorporate the fact that,
that the fidelity of the model in terms
of how well it describes the data
and how would you use it, right.
Like say you have those models.
- [Priya] Yeah.
- How are you going to use it?
So I think about things kind
of in a sort of reinforcement
learning or decision
making kind of scenario,
which is if I'm going
to use this for planning
like one way of thing about world models
that makes them very
concrete is when you think
about using them for
planning or decision making.
Right.
And so that helps ground
the thinking a little bit,
which is, yeah.
You know, how are if you did have them
and that the different levels of accuracy
and different like trade offs in terms
of how expensive they are to run,
you know, what would you do?
And that's not quite answering you're,
the deeper question, which is like,
how do you come up with
them in the first place?
But I think it's probably
something to think about
at the beginning, cuz it's gonna guide
a lot of the way that you organize it
and think about things but it
it's very interesting
and I mean the other,
well, we have doing some
exploratory thing right now,
which is like kind of you hopping
between these like game
of life type cellular,
ATO things you have some very low level
model that describes kind
of how things evolve.
But sometimes you get these
sort of emergent phenomena
that look like little organisms that walk
and they can run into each other
and collide or do something,
you know?
And if you wanted to try to figure out
how the long time behavior
of one of these things,
like, and then maybe
and there might be interactions.
Like if you know that
you make a little Walker
and it's moving along,
like at some point you don't need
to resolve all these details.
You just zoom along until it looks like
they're gonna collide.
Right.
But there's this interesting
part where you kind
of hop up and down between
like once they go collide,
then you need to drop into
the low level picture.
It's like exactly how are they hitting
and model that.
And then, so that ability,
like the fact that we're even
having this conversation.
Right, right.
Like I just,
in very few words
explained something that's
in my mind and you know,
the you kind of know
what I'm saying,
maybe, you know, I don't like,
but this jumping back and forth between
the levels it's...
- Right, right.
- Very important to me, it
seems very, very important.
And how you do that is a good question.
So I think one part is just to give,
start with them and then
see how you use them.
And then maybe that
gives them some guidance.
- Yeah.
I guess like another example I think of is
suppose I go to work
and I put in my bag a
flask or a water bottle,
I don't need to reason
about all the fluid dynamics
of the water inside the bottle as I,
as able to work.
But when I get out and
I need to actually pour
the water into a glass,
now I do need to actually reasonable
this kinda lower level dynamics.
And so it seems like
there's flexible ability
to jump between different representations,
different levels of fidelity seems key.
And then prior to that, it's just like,
how do we even represent
these different levels
in a coherent structure?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- But also, I mean, isn't
this also something obsessed,
something about the task
of filtering, right.
That we are filtering, as you know,
when you look at that water
bottle and you put it down,
somehow you already know
the quantum mechanics
of how the plastic
molecules are oscillating.
One is completely irrelevant
and that it's not a level
that you need to access information or in,
for anything from you're
filtering that out somehow.
Right.
And whereas when you pour,
you still understand that you
don't worry about the plastic,
but you do need to worry
about the water molecules
and the equations of
fluid, fluid mechanics.
Right.
Which you didn't have to before.
So I wonder if it's,
I keep liking to think it's
some kind of filtering,
but maybe it's not
filtering maybe filtering
isn't the right word for it.
- No, I think, yeah.
I think you you're right.
Like somehow you need
to know what's relevant.
It kind of reminds me of this kind
of famous philosophical problem
called the frame problem.
Then has a paper on it.
It's like,
how do you know what's relevant
without actually having
already know, you know, having right.
(indistinct)
Like, how do I know?
I don't need to use the
level fluid dynamics before,
you know, until without actually using it.
Right.
And so I don't think we have
actually any competi answers
to this question.
- And this is why I asked,
do you think there's something hardwired?
I mean, is there some,
are there forms of innate knowledge
that we already have of the world?
And, you know,
I look at a lot of these experiments
that cognitive scientists
with infants do, right.
Like infant cognition.
And they do talk about how we
probably have some hardwired
notion of counting, like
so because if you give a
little infant like three blocks
and then you take away one, they go where,
because they kind of know
that there's something
has changed.
Right.
But I don't know whether
they're going where,
because they actually know
that the number has gone down
or some other attribute right.
When God knows what, you know.
- Yeah.
It seems like having some notion
of core knowledge is
crucial for learning the
kinds of things that humans
learn at the same time.
It does seem like we do
have a certain amount
of flexibility.
So going to the point that
Kyle just made like this zoom
this conversation we're having,
but even down to like the zoom core.
Right.
So how do I use zoom?
I press a button and somehow magically
I get connected.
I don't know underneath that,
there's there's TCP IP,
there's like electrons whizzing around.
I don't need to reason
about all that to know how
to connect zoom call, but I might right.
If zoom stops, stops working.
Right.
And so I, you know,
I don't think zoom is kind
of hard to call natively
into my brain or human's brain.
Right.
But maybe something more
abstract like notions of objects
and notions of actions are kind of...
- I mean,
there's a little bit of
chicken and egg stuff going
on here too, which is,
of course we build these interfaces to fit
the things that we know.
And also a lot of the examples
that we're giving are play
where the world does
seem to organize itself
in this kind of hierarchical way with kind
of ni you know, what's,
what's a little bit, you know,
when you get into the
particle physics side of it
and you see like the
separation of scales there,
it has like a very
precise mathematical way.
And one of the things
that's pretty interesting
is that within quantum field theory,
there's actually like really
deep statements about,
about why the world
does separate itself out
into these scales.
And that's like a, it's not really clear,
it's not obvious at all
that you would be able to
make such strong statements
but when you then go
into things that are like
when you start talking like society or
some really complex system,
it's not really clear that the,
that there is any concise definition.
I mean, like a description of the system.
I mean, maybe we're just
not smart enough to see it,
but it's also quite possible
that there just isn't some,
you know, smaller degree of
freedom reduced description.
If you're in you know,
if we were kind of like
cognizant or conscious
at that scale, like that scale of things,
maybe we wouldn't be
having this discussion
we wouldn't be like presuming things.
So that that's actually a useful concept
to like break things down.
And I think I'll just say that to me,
this is also important.
I mentioned in my talk,
this kind of no free lunch statement.
And I think it's also true
when you look at like what's
going on with like success and
deep learning is that there
there's a co-evolution
of the architectures
of deep learning and evolution,
neural networks and things,
and the kinds of problems
that people were working on,
which were mainly image
like problems at first.
Right.
And then when you go to data
that has a very different
character to it, those models may
or may not work well.
Right.
And so and if you really take yourself
into the extreme of like any
possible kind of data set coming in,
so that you really allow yourself like
basically totally
unstructured looking data,
then basically on average,
everything is equally good or bad
and there isn't,
there's no like magic bullet out there.
Right.
So like we, so it's, you know,
so it's important to remember that yeah.
The extent that any of these
things that we're talking
about it or going to
like work or be useful
or anything like that
is always gonna be within the context
of some domain of application.
And which is also
reassuring because otherwise
it's like, it's a, it
sounds, it's a right.
So.
(Kyle laughs)
- But anyway, so I think
it is five 30 and there
is one more question
that I would like you,
and that's for Kyle from the ad from SBI,
the advent of powerful
machine learning methods
is enabling practitioners to work directly
with high dimensional data
and to reduce the reliance
on expert craft summary statistics.
So does the introduction
of quantum machine learning
or similar techniques or algorithms point
to any qualitative rethinking
of the above statement?
- Well, I'm trying to think.
I mean, in a very, it seems like
if quantum to machine learning
or something comes to play,
it seems like it would
only either it's going
to not be useful or it's
gonna make it more powerful.
Right.
So, and if it's,
so I think my statement is basically
that previously we didn't,
we really relied on
expert knowledge to try
to navigate through this complicated data
and structure it in a way that
we could work with kind
of more of computational
and statistical methods.
And when you pair it
with machine learning,
we can now re relieve the
pressure on the expert
and kind of automate some of
that process, which is good.
And I think you.
- Can't completely get
rid of domain knowledge.
You're still,
you still rely on domain knowledge, right?
- Yeah.
Well, I think it,
that gets into a little
bit of a question of,
are you just trying to this
particular task at hand,
are you trying to do the bigger
the bigger thing I think
if you really just want the task at hand
could pretty surprisingly good
at some pretty automated stuff
it's just that if anything
goes unexpected leader,
like you sort of find this,
like, what do you do next?
If you can't kind of connect what's going
on in this automated way back
to your domain knowledge,
then you don't know what to do.
And until we get to the point
that we have like much more powerful AI
that knows how to generate
hypotheses and design
expert and the kinds of things
that then it was discussing
it's important that
humans can touch base with
that for quantum machine
learning in particular.
I don't, I think some of that
stuff is a bit speculative.
It's exciting.
But I think if that stuff works out well,
it seems like it's just gonna
enhance the capabilities
of machine learning and maybe so yeah,
I don't know that it really changes my,
that particular statement,
but it certainly will
influence the landscape.
(laughs)
Yeah.
- So any closing thoughts
before we wrap up?
- I think there's been really
I appreciate the discussion
and I, the whole series I think
has been pretty interesting.
And thank you for having me.
- Little, thank you so much.
Yeah.
Thank you so much, Zenna.
Thank you so much,
Kyle, for taking the time and...
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
And this was a wonderful
sort of in depth discussion.
So I just wanna thank
everyone for attending
and look forward to seeing
you at our next event.
And our next event is
actually gonna be a book talk
by Carl Zimmer on his latest book.
So that's next week.
So I will see you all take care and bye.
Thanks very much.